[Music]
as numberland's best detective you
thought you'd seen it all but the
desiccated corpses of prominent natural
numbers whole numbers greater than zero
have been showing up all over the city
for the past week
all of digitalis is on lockdown from
sundown to sunrise and it's still not
enough to stop what can only be
described as a vampiric feeding frenzy
the police are helpless and have turned
to you you put the missing person's case
you've been investigating on hold and
study the evidence
here's what you know
most victims have been completely
drained of their life's essence some
have a thin line of slime separating
digits some of which were drained and
others spared
which leads you to mystery one what's
the significance of the slime lines and
why are certain digits untouched
[Music]
let's start by looking for a pattern in
the victims why have some been fully
drained and some slimed well the slime
lined are in their prime which is to say
they're prime numbers divisible only by
one and themselves not a single one of
the unslimed numbers on the other hand
is
furthermore the drained parts of the
slimed primes are not themselves prime
when 71 got slimed seven was prime but
one was not
if 461 had been split into 4 and 61 the
right side would have been prime but
instead it was split further into
non-prime digits and when 2099 got
slimed the attacker went with 20 and 99
and was able to drain both
so you have a big problem there are
infinite potential victims all non-prime
numbers and all prime numbers that can
be slimelined to reveal at least one
non-prime number
in fact you can only think of a few
numbers that aren't vulnerable first of
all the one-digit primes two three five
and seven
then primes like 23 which could only be
split into 2 and 3 both prime
these numbers are familiar but why
aha your missing person's case
someone is kidnapping the numbers that
can't be drained we'll call them the
immune if you can identify the four
immune who remain perhaps you can get to
them first and figure out what's going
on
who are the immune
there are four one digit immune two
three five and seven
all have already been kidnapped but
every digit in all of the immune must be
one of those four numbers otherwise
there would be a non-prime split
possible
that means there are only these 16
candidates among the two digit numbers
the ones that are prime must be immune
we can eliminate anything that ends in
two or five as they'll always be
divisible by two and five this diagonal
is also out as they're divisible by
eleven
if the digits of a number add up to a
multiple of 3 it's divisible by 3 so
that eliminates 57 and 27 leaving these
numbers which upon double checking are
in fact immune
we now have a strong starting point for
searching three digit numbers any two
consecutive digits must be on the list
of the two digit immune
those all end in three and seven so the
only possibilities are these eight
options the two-digit immune with
additional threes or sevens on their
ends
three can't follow three nor seven
follow seven and once again adding the
digits reveals that 237
and 537 are divisible by 3.
737 is 67 times 11 so that leaves just
373
which is in fact prime and therefore
immune
could a four digit number be immune no
any consecutive three digits would have
to be immune and there's no immune
three-digit number that starts with a
seven you rush out but reach each home
too late until the only immune left is
373
you're in the nick of time to scare off
her would-be kidnapper not the vampire
itself but a minion
373 explains that she and the other
immune are the subjects of an ancient
prophecy that designated them as vampire
slayers
they'd sometimes gather and try to
figure out what a vampire is but no one
had the slightest idea they found the
idea of slaying things quite distasteful
you both trail her would-be kidnapper
back to a foreboding castle there you
release the other kidnapped numbers and
confront the vampire himself
he's powerless before the slayers but
ever the pacifists they round him up
return the life force to his victims and
send him packing numberland is safe
for
now love a good mathematical mystery who
here is lying watson hudson or sherlock
knowing that you can turn the light on
and off you can test your answer to this
and many other interactive lessons and
exercises at brilliant in recent months
brilliant has been revamping their
courses to introduce even more
interactivity and their brand new logic
course is a great example
packed with opportunities for hands-on
problem solving exercises like this one
help you look at problems in a
completely new way go to brilliant.org
ted dash ed today and the first 833 of
you to use that link will receive 20 off
the annual premium subscription fee